(calm electronic music)
- [Narrator] I just like
it when my kids get up,
and they're in a good mood
and they're all smiling.
That's my bit, the first bit of the day.
- [Narrator] Family don't cost nothing.
It's like your mom is
like your best friend.
(whistling)
- [Narrator] She puts on a big smiling face.
She's only one; she's
small, but she's lovely.
- [Narrator] I like being outside.
So, like when the weather's really
warm, I like looking at trees.
- [Narrator] Me, and I make
it for me, for my dress
is a lovely color, and
it's a proud feeling.
I am happy.
- [Narrator] It's strangers smiling.
It's strangers dancing with strangers.
That's what's community.
- [Narrator] The sound that the bike makes
when he's arriving at home
just makes me very happy
because, yeah.
- [Narrator] I like having a
bacon sandwich on my balcony.
(laughter)
- [Narrator] So I would
be very happy, likely.
- [Narrator] Probably friends because
they're always there for you.
- [Narrator] Finding
dinosaurs in the fruit bowl.
That makes me happy.
- [Narrator] Going different places,
meeting different people
and different cultures.
- [Narrator] Just that
gentleman over there.
He makes me happy.
- [Narrator] Cycling with my mates.
- [Narrator] Playing Legos.
- [Narrator] Live music.
- I love pizza.
- Coffee?
- [Narrator] Her laugh, her
laugh is really, really crazy.